pire une bêche et goal of comme
professeur invité à l'université d'état
de moscou
bonjour calmer ses douleurs
merci d'être en direct avec nous sur
arte france 78% de huy 65 % de taux de
participation votre réaction sur ces
chiffres définitifs et et quid de la
popularité de vladimir poutine
bonjour en effet ces chiffres montrent
un soutien massif de la population à
l'idée portée par cette réforme
constitutionnelle qui est à la fois une
affirmation des valeurs traditionnelles
puisqu'on le voit on y voit la mention
de dieu on y voit la conception
traditionnelle de la famille c'est aussi
un oui massif à les mesures de
protection de la souveraineté de la
russie dans un monde de plus en plus
global monde dans lequel la russie
participe en revanche réduira à cwi
massif de la réforme constitutionnelle à
un simple soutien inconditionnel à
vladimir poutine pour quasiment advitam
en fait être président du pays je pense
que ce serait une erreur stratégique
majeure
justement la plupart des médias
occidentaux insistent sur la possibilité
pour le dit mr poutine d'effectuer de
nouveaux mandats présidentiels mais
outre cette mesure il existe beaucoup
d'autres amendements qu'est ce qui a
suscité plus d'attention de la part des
russes dans ce référendum étalée sur une
semaine
il faut comprendre que dans ce concept
dans cette réforme constitutionnelle il
y a deux types en fonction ne parle pas
de de la nidification des mandats
antérieure de vladimir poutine il ya
deux types de modifications y ait des
modifications de type technique
juridique qu'ils renforcent la
participation des différents types des
mécanismes entre l'exécutif le
législatif et le judiciaire mettant en
place une certaine complexification des
rapports de pouvoir
je ne pense pas que ce genre de
mécanismes techniques et
particulièrement intéresser la
population qui n'est pas juriste et
c'est tout à fait normal donc la
population elle s'est beaucoup plus
vce à des déclarations d'intention gps
politique idéologique c'est à dire aux
valeurs qui sont celles de la russie et
que la russie veut défendre et veut
affirmer dans un monde qui est appelée
de plus en plus progressistes mais dont
la progression n'est pas forcément une
amélioration après cette adoption quelle
suite au niveau du calendrier alors il
n'y aura évidemment pas de dissolution
du parlement il n'y aura évidemment pas
de remise à plat du gouvernement en tout
cas sur le fondement de cette réforme
constitutionnelle puisque des hangars
vont continuer à fonctionner normalement
jusqu'à la fin de leur mandat
ces nouvelles dispositions vont d'être
mise en place derrière un niveau
discussions techniques la suite à
l'adoption du de la réforme
constitutionnelle par le vote
elle va entrer en vigueur dès que la
commission électorale aura
officiellement annoncer les résultats
ce qui ne va pas tarder puisque de toute
façon les résultats maintenant sont déjà
connus il ya eu quelques problèmes mais
absolument mineurs 4k de discutables ce
qui n'a fait absolument pas ce le
résultat général du vote
donc si vous voulez derrière il y à la
vie ne va pas changer aujourd'hui du
jour au lendemain en russie en revanche
ans la population a clairement indiqué
qu' elle ne veut pas que le territoire
national soit négocié discuté ce qui
règle la question des îles kouriles
elle ne veut pas que les pseudo valeurs
occidentales qui sont une dénégation de
la valeur humaine malheureusement
aujourd'hui entre en russie
donc ça va permettre en quelque sorte de
mettre un certain filtra à ses montées
que l'on voit des lobbys lgbt à ses
montées que l'on voit des login lancé
sur la question des violences féminine
et s'est faite aux femmes etc
ça ce sont des certaine protection
puisque
la population s'est prononcée de façon
claire nette absolument sans appel les
élites politiques quelles que soient
leurs convictions
indépendamment du nombre de passeports
qu'ils ont dans les poches vont être
obligés de suivre cette votation
populaire parce que la russie à la
différence de la france ou de pays de
l'union européenne as-tu néji timité qui
vient de la base c'est à dire que la
population réellement donne d'elle
légitimité au gouvernement un
gouvernement en russie ne peut pas se
permettre comme en france de fonctionner
avec 30% popularité ou 20 pouces en
popularité un chef d'état dans ce cas là
ce serait exploser littéralement pays
dernière question rapidement l'opposant
à l'effet une havane et dénonce des
falsifications et donne rendez vous aux
prochaines élections régionales
qu'est-ce qu'il faut attendre de ce
futur scrutin
je ne suis pas certaine en tout cas que
l'on puisse attendre grand chose de neuf
années a déjà parce que la moyenne d'âge
des personnes qui en général peut mettre
dans la rue n'ont absolument pas la
gelée pouvoir voter donc c'est de la
communication ça ne va pas plus loin
c'est un peu comme l'ambassade
américaine qui l'ambassade comporte anne
qui lance un drapeau alger était sur le
toit de leur ambassade à moscou au
moment du vote des constitutions des
arguments constitutionnels
nous sommes uniquement dans le cadre des
symboles de toutes façons la population
c'est assez prononcé de façon très
clairement les falsifications ont été
absolument un film les quatre cas à
douteux léa les résultats ont été
annulés dans ces cas de doute il y à une
enquête en cours
mais sanaa flammes sont passées aux
états des élections donc il n'y aura pas
de modification fondamentale
après au niveau des élections locales ça
va dépendre de la capacité des élites
locales à tenir compte non seulement des
indications qui leur sont donnés deux
par le haut mais surtout des besoins
réels de la population autrement dit
d'être politique et pas seulement
manager merci car and the goal of quoi
d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes professeur invité
à l'université d'état de moscou